Hello,大家好,我是乐顺。今天乐顺给大家带来一个增强版唐奇安通道策略。
提起唐奇安通道,很多人都会联想到海归交易法则。
这也许是有史以来最成功的交易员培训课程。
海归们用神奇的交易系统赚了成百上千万美元,
直到1983年海归交易法则才解密。
人们发现这个神奇的交易系统用的正是修正版的唐奇安通道
但时过境迁
现在的市场环境已经发生了很大的变化
这导致唐奇安通道策略变得低效
那么今天我们试着改进唐奇安策略
来看看增强版的唐奇安通道策略效果如何
我们看一下唐前通道的原始策略逻辑
是由过去N天最高价的最大值
画出一条阻力线
由过去N天最低价的最小值
画出一条支撑线
当价格向上突破阻力线时买入
当价格向下跌破支撑线时卖出
那么我们根据原始策略的逻辑进行改进
改进后的策略逻辑就是建立上下中轨三轨
上轨由过去N天的最高价的最大值乘上涨系数形成
下轨由过去N天的最低价的最小值乘下跌系数形成
中轨由上轨加下轨的和除以2
那么根据上下中轨三轨诱件的开平仓逻辑就是
当前无持仓并且价格突破上轨,我们进行多头仓位的建立。
当当前无持仓并且价格跌破下轨,我们进行空头仓位的建立。
当当前持多仓并且价格跌破中轨,我们进行平多头仓位的操作。
当当前持空单并且价格突破中轨,我们进行平空头仓位的操作。
设计完开平仓逻辑之后
我们进入到代码的设计与实现环节
首先点击浏览器
打开发明者量化交易平台点击控制中心点击策略库点击新建策略策略名称我们命名为一个改进昂旗安通道策略
然后进入到代码的编辑部分
首先我们写入一个Viltro循环
来构建整个逻辑的轮循体
然后我们需要定义一个antic函数,antic函数中是写入我们策略的主要逻辑部分,然后在wheel处循环体中引入antic函数。
在执行完antic函数中的内容之后,我们调取sleep函数,使得轮循体休息一秒钟,防止轮循过快。
在轮询体中我们首先通过重视函数
再加上一个exchange set contract type函数
来设置我们的合约类型
设置的合约类型
我们通过一个参数将其引入
我们定一个symbol参数
然后在这里我们将合约类型初始设定为RB000
来用于我们的回测
然后将Symbol引入
然后我们定一个K线数组变量
BioArray
同样的通过一个重视函数
对Exchange.getRecurs函数来进行容错处理
然后通过If条件语句来判断
我们返回的BioArray数组长度是否符合我们的要求
为了后期方便
调整我们的长度要求
在这里我们设计一个变量circle length
并将其初始值设置为60
然后通过if语句来判断
其长度是否小于circle length
如果小于circle length的话
我们提前退出并重新进入antique
然后我们需要定一个close last变量
来获取我们上根K线的收盘价
在这里为什么要获取上根K线呢因为我们的最后一根K线是处于变化之中的是具有豁然性的所以说我们要取到已经确定了的上一根K线的收盘价
同样的道理
我们对我们的BioRail数组进行去掉最后一个值的操作
也是为了获得具有确定性的数据
处理完我们的数据之后
我们就可以进行计算上轨与下轨还有中轨了
我们定义online是我们的上轨
通过调取TA库中的highless函数
然后向其中传参
Bowry以及确定的一个周期数
我们在这里定义为55
然后传入一个属性值
也就是我们要取到该周期下最高价中的最大值
然后乘以一个上涨系数
我们在这里将上涨系数定义为0.999
该系数可以根据使用者对于品种的了解
以及对未来行情的预判进行调整
然后我们计算我们的下轨
同样的调取我们TA库中的Lost弹数
将我们的相应的参数传入Lost弹数中
分别是我们的K线数组
我们的周期数以及我们的属性值
然后乘以1.001
也就是我们的下跌系数
然后我们中轨的计算就是上轨加上下轨的值除以2
我们定义为中轨middle line
是我们的上轨online加上我们的下轨的和除以2
那么现在我们有了上下中三轨的值了之后
我们就可以进行开平仓的逻辑的构建
首先我们需要定一个参数虚拟持仓MP
为了管理我们的持仓状态
在此处我们将MP进行全局化
然后我们书写当持多仓的时候的平仓的逻辑
如果MP大于0并且close last小于我们的中轨
此时我们需要平多头仓位
在这里我们需要引入非并发交易控制类
我们首先将非并发交易控制类进行实力化
在这里我们需要将我们的交易类库进行勾选
在把我们的非并发交易控制类进行实力化之后
我们通过调取该类中的cover函数进行平仓平仓之后我们更新虚拟持仓的状态为0然后就是我们的平空头仓位的逻辑的书写
当我们的最近的收盘价大于中轨的时候
我们进行空头仓位的平仓
同样的调用非并发交易控制类中的cover击数进行平仓
平仓之后我们的持仓状态为0
然后进行我们开仓逻辑的书写
如果我们的仓位状态为0
那么如果我们的最近的收盘价是大于我们的上轨
我们进行开多仓的操作
通过调取非并发交易控制类中的openlum函数
开一手的多仓
并更新虚拟池汤的状态为一手多仓
那么开空仓的状态
就是当我们的最近的收盘价跌破了我们的下轨
我们通过调取非并发交易控制类中的
OpenShot函数来进行我们空头仓位的建立
空头仓位建立之后
我们更新虚拟持仓为-1
那么到此为止
一个改进版的堂前通道策略的代码部分
就书写完成了
我们将其代入到回测系统中
来看一下表现如何
经过回测我们可以看到
改进版的堂前通道策略表现良好
这就告诉我们
做什么事情都要与时俱进
才能不落伍不被淘汰
这也给我们提供了一个思路
通过改进已经过时的量化策略的部分逻辑
是可以使古老的量化策略焕发新生的
所以成功的方法有时候可能不仅仅是开辟新的路径
也有可能是在固守本来的基础上的进取得来的
那么到此为止
一个增强版的杭其安通道策略的讲解就结束了
乐顺在这里
希望每一位量化投资者都可以通过设计
与实现自己的量化策略来获取理想中的收益
最后祝大家享受投资快乐量化
谢谢大家